a gente está falando sobre consciência e
atitude e nós todos queremos segurança
nós buscamos isso queremos sair numa
cidade segura mas o que nós estamos
fazendo para mudar essa realidade que
vem aumentando a violência e que essa
atual política de encarceramento não dá
conta e não já está provado que não
resolve do brasil em 2014 um milhão de
brasileiros passaram em presídios e
penitenciárias de acordo com os dados do
departamento de execução prisional depen
e não foram só um milhão de pessoas que
que estiveram no presídio foram 1 milhão
de famílias
multiplique então assim directamente
expor 5 uma família pequenininha tá uma
família com cinco pessoas que
vivenciaram lugares com assim com total
e dignidade então 5 milhões de pessoas
diretamente e visitando presídios
crianças visitando o presídio
nessa situação ea gente tá fazendo
alguma coisa assim a gente critica
muita gente critica né fala bandido bom
é bandido morto ou muitas vezes ouvi
dizer pra mim leva pra casa deles eu já
levei eu já levei e levo mas não é uma
não é uma não não há uma consciência de
que de que esse discurso de ódio que a
gente acaba ouvindo se tem que ser mais
que discurso mais do que uma crítica a
gente precisa saber quem são essas
pessoas que estão lá dentro quem são
quem são essas pessoas e dados da vara
de execução criminal se eu pegar o
presídio que eu faço o projeto
em porto alegre o presídio central de
porto alegre a ponto que 20 e 21 de
jovens são jovens os detentos em torno
de 25 anos desempregados que se quer
possui o ensino fundamental e 28 por
cento dessa população no presídio são
crimes relacionados ao tráfico de drogas
a gente está vendo que muitas pessoas
que falaram por aqui falaram de
visibilidade ea invisibilidade no
cárcere é muito forte no brasil hoje
desconheço um outro projeto que trabalha
essa questão de uma plataforma de
expressão de detentos em regime fechado
no brasil a gente vê muita
espetacularização da mídia e aquela sede
pela pelo sangue audiência né
vamos lá acompanhar o policial achar um
responsável pelo crime e colocar toda
aquela carga em cima de um jovem que
também está cheio de sonhos e
expectativas e que faltou muitas vezes
uma oportunidade né então a gente a
gente tem que trabalhar esse discurso de
que desse discurso de intolerância e
sair dessa desse de cid gomes desse
ciclo e mostrar que atrás de um de um
rosto assim que a gente trabalhou essa
imagem do primeiro ciclo de estudos
direito no cárcere
e nós trouxemos é a idéia da
invisibilidade daí eles colocaram essa
máscara ea gente mostrou quem são essas
pessoas do projeto ele busca trabalhar
isso é na época agora o dn já está em
liberdade
a gente trabalha muito muito com
tecnologia eu preciso dizer que eu já
faço trabalho social há dez anos mas eu
nunca tinha feito um trabalho social e
num espaço tão precário né a minha
primeira experiência com cárcere foi no
rio de janeiro e nova iguaçu
a oportunidade que eu que eu pude assim
ver de perto né as condições ea
dificuldade que essas pessoas em redes e
aquilo me disse assim eu faço já um
trabalho social para pessoas que têm
alguma condição porque não vou lá sabes
eu tenho isso já faz o evento já faz um
projeto de ti jornal então por que não
posso fazer dentro do presídio
eu visitei uma turma de visitei junto
quando eu voltei pra
alegre procurei o professor professor
celso do ipa e ele tem um grupo de
direitos humanos à prisão e eu fui
acompanhar a turma de alunos nesse
projeto e e via a mais a parte técnica e
estrutural entrei numa cela mas não
tinha conversado lá nesse um presente
então não tinha conversado com o preso e
como eu sou muito insistente deu certo
já que eu quero fazer eu comecei a
visitar o diretor na época o major
augusto eu ia semanalmente lá na sala do
diretor e eu acho que neto quanto fica
ela tem que dar uma utilidade para a
guria né tá ali então daí um dia estava
tendo uma reunião do dados do judiciário
tava ministério público assim japur tava
enfim vários membros assim que estavam
tentando criar uma galeria de tratamento
de dependência química tem que criar a
galeria galeria e um luz no cárcere
e daí eu estava lá naquele dia deles bom
caminho já que tu tá entanto fica
responsável com um dia de atividade
só que daí foi um susto assim não é
porque um dia de atividade e pensei meu
deus deitar não vou fazer sim eu vou
fazer mas como é que eu vou fazer é um
dia de atividade lá porque eu faço o
evento mais um evento de uma hora duas
um dia dentro de uma galeria e daí com o
passar do tempo a esses vínculos nem
comecei a fazer as atividades sempre era
acompanhada de uma escolta né e os
policiais também não me conhecia então
tinha e ainda tem mais a gente quebra
isso uma cultura muito forte é de que as
pessoas estão lá dentro que elas fizeram
algum crime praticar algum crime não não
merece ser tratada pelo nome baixa e aí
cabeça baixa e boca debaixo do braço
não olha pra pessoa é assim rápido é
tratado desse jeito e e assim as regras
para a coisa funciona é assim mas isso
foi diminuindo assim essa essa visão
policial assim foi diminuindo na na
medida que o meu laço com os detentos
foi aumentando e que e que chegou o
momento em que os presos fizeram um
apetite
não dizendo que eles fariam a minha
segurança porque entrou de greve a
polícia ea polícia não queria deixar eu
entrar e eu tive que falar com os juízes
é que eu queria entrar lá e que eu não
precisava de segurança que já entrava
sozinho então eles fizeram uma carta do
juízo nós não responsabilizamos pela
pura pela carmela e por quem mais entrar
aqui e isso foi foi muito importante
assim porque é mostrou é que a gente que
quem está lá dentro não é um uma pessoa
para pessoa do mal a pessoa tem uma
índole má porque matou porque não sei o
quê
e muita gente né que rotular as pessoas
e não é assim que funciona porque pra
gente morrer e pra gente cometeu um
crime é um sabe a gente já tá comédia
faz um passe um sinal vermelho está
cometendo uma infração está tão mal
sonega imposto e também está cometendo
uma infração e quem tá quem não pede
nota fiscal também tá sabe então vai
muito da nossa visão do que é do que é
um crime
então a gente precisa retirar suas
algemas mentais e começar a enxergar a
enxergar essa população porque se a
gente a gente pode ver mas enxergar
diferente se a gente não tiver uma
janela de visibilidade para essa
população
a gente vai continuar vendo que a
televisão nos mostra do jeito que eles
querem dizer e achando que realmente ele
é perigoso tem mais é que apodrecer e
não é por aí que funciona nessa foto
aqui é foi um dia que a gente tava com
uma oficina de rádio e um dos
entrevistados ele foi preso saiu hoje
faz faculdade e assistência social e foi
lá dar uma entrevista para o programa de
rádio que a gente tirou chamado a voz no
cárcere com h
existe voz está na internet a gente faz
assim com o trabalho de voluntários né e
conforme a gente consegue recursos e
pessoas para fazer a gente tem
essa disponibilidade ea gente procura
nesse espaço de tempo lá dentro
trabalhar o deus da organização do tempo
que a gente vai fazer o que a gente vai
planejar a gente vai pintar galeria
quando é que a gente vai convidar os
familiares como é que a gente vai fazer
esse movimento e é uma forma bem
interessante de porque eles têm uma
organização própria mas eles têm uma
organização da rotina deles então a
gente precisa organizar o tempo pra
criar pra que eles têm um desenvolver
suas capacidades que estão todas elas
dentro deles então por exemplo quando a
gente faz uma entrevista de rádio o
preso em treviso próprio peso e é muito
interessante porque teve uma entrevista
que a gente fez que era o andarilho e
daí ele falou como era a vida o um
camarão a pele dele e falou da vida como
é que era ser um andarilho né e e as
pessoas acabam se conhecendo mais né
então isso é só um exemplo de atividade
né e ea internet isso tudo ela sempre
foi um meio de fazer com que a gente
aproximar-se primeiramente as famílias e
aproximar se a sociedade para abrir um
diálogo e de e fazer uma nova cultura a
cultura já estava lá dentro nós já
estávamos construindo uma cultura a
partir do momento que eu não se entra
mais um brigadiano a partir do momento
que existe em outros hábitos lá a partir
do momento que a gente consegue falar de
outras idéias que não há violência e
planejar alguma coisa porque se a pessoa
não tem o que fazer ela vai trocar as
experiências dela e de repente as
experiências dela realmente forem
negativas assim no sentido de ji de
perdas e de ram assalto de tráfego e
realmente eles vão ficar nesse nesse
círculo mas a gente tem que abrir um
ambiente para que isso se for pra que
isso se desenvolva porque todo mundo tem
sabe a primeira vez que a gente levou
uma banda dentro da galeria foi do meu
colega de protásio alves gustavo nunes e
foi muito importante
assim ele está num eles ficavam mais
inibidos
no início os braços cruzados e ainda
entrava com o policial mas foi uma coisa
que depois que ele foi para lá e que a
gente mostrou isso na internet muitas
outras bandas já passaram por lá ea
música é muito presente no trabalho
eu gosto muito do do neurocientista
português antónio damásio porque ele
falava ele estuda como já ouvi a
história diz é muito tempo já fala sobre
o modo como a gente procura conhecer a
aperceber é o conhecimento e eu também
procuro trabalhar isso da sensibilização
dos sentidos então como é que a gente
aprende se e se esse conhecimento
a gente pode o direito nem de uma
maneira sisuda gente pode aprender uma
maneira negativa e uma maneira positiva
então existe várias maneiras e o antónio
damásio ele fala numa experiência que
quando a gente consegue mudar a nossa
percepção acontece ou quando tem algum
acontecimento representativo na nossa
vida acontece o que ele chama de
homeostase sociocultural então eu gosto
muito de trabalhar com isso eu gosto de
trabalhar no que no mesmo ambiente onde
a pessoa teve experiências terríveis
experiências muito tristes
ele consiga ter uma experiência boa e é
tão boa que depois quando ele sai do
presídio ele usa foto para votar nas
redes sociais
então isso é um paradigma que a gente
quebra muito importante que é mudar a
experiência negativa que ele tinha
daquele espaço por uma experiência de
construção de de fortalecimento de
identidade e de se encontrar esse dia
foi bastante importante e e foi o dia
que a gente foi a primeira vez que eu
pintei a galeria com os presos ea gente
pintou mais do que a galeria gente
pintou a nossa vida a gente construiu
deu novas cores e foi a primeira vez que
a gente coletivamente se tocou e foi
tocado pelo outro né foi um dia muito
importante tem esse vídeo na internet e
e a gente fica a gente cada vez que faz
esse trabalho de pintura que é todo ano
a gente procura fazer
todos os presos se unem a gente faz essa
revitalização do espaço
é muito importante a gente trabalhar
revitalização do lugar trabalhar com que
essa apropriação do lugar aconteça por
eles próprios e da nossa vida também de
gente cuidar do nosso espaço e está no
espaço limpo mais humanizado também dá
uma condição emocional para que a pessoa
também esteja e possa perceber mais
sente outras coisas dentro dela então
tem essas reformas periódicas
todo ano a gente faça esse ciclo de
estudos direito no cárcere e o nome do
projeto é direito no cárcere porque a
gente trabalha o direito nas suas várias
perspectivas desde o direito à saúde
desde o direito à família desde o dos
mais diversos direitos mas no caso e
tenta tirar o direito em cárcere né
porque as pessoas acham que direito às
vezes tem que ser só para alguns
né e acho também que entregar para o
terceiro é a melhor solução para
resolver conflitos só que num não
funciona isso
nós temos uma tendência muito grande
assim de judicialização da vida e pra
cortar com isso o nosso protagonismo tem
que aumentar
tem que se envolver e essa esse
envolvimento gerou essa é uma voluntária
que está abraçada com o pai é o henry a
paula a paula viu o pai dela não viu o
pai de não conversava com o pai dela há
oito anos e ela foi numa palestra do
procurador de justiça gilmar bortolotto
numa casa espírita e quando o avião se
depara com a foto do pai dentro da
cadeia no projeto e tal mais gordinho é
porque a droga deixa as pessoas muito
fragilizadas e ficou emocionada falou
com gilmar e disse eu quero ir lá
visitar meu pai
e aí foi aquela imagem que fez a retomar
voltar a ter um vínculo com o pai então
foi um dia bem emocionante e que a gente
trabalha muito essa questão de como uma
imagem pode a fazer resgate de vínculos
né e consciência
hoje que a gente tem que trabalhar né a
consciência pra gente tirar o antónio
damásio diz também que para a gente ter
empatia nós precisamos ter consciência
sem consciência a gente não tem empatia
e eu acredito que pra gente poder também
ter consciência das coisas a gente tem
que sair do nosso lugar de conforto
esse aproximados dos problemas se
aproximado que nos fazem diferentes
assim das situações que nos torna
diferentes porque a gente tem muito a
aprender
nesses espaços e essa cultura acaba se
mudando também quando a gente olha gente
cria essa e essa janela de memórias né
que a gente tem pela fotografia pelo
vídeo
a gente trabalha o direito à memória no
sistema prisional porque as pessoas
casam as pessoas têm filhos as pessoas
envelhecem e a maioria hoje no brasil
não tem uma foto sua individual e isso é
pode parecer e tipo mas isso é muito
importante dentro que eu iniciei o
projeto uma das imagens que mais eu vejo
nos álbuns dos mesmos nos dias que eu
percorro que eu passo dentro da cadeia
eles tiram uma foto de frente para o
espelho então eu vejo muito significado
nessa imagem de eles conseguirem
enxergar eles tiram uma foto no espelho
acho que isso representa apresenta a
representa muito em nossa hoje em dia
nos preocupamos com todos os crimes
será que a gente está atento a todos os
crimes hoje sou a população realmente
está um crime que tipo de crime que a
população está mais a pegar nesse
momento atual política acho que está
muito em voga em voga a questão da
corrupção
e quando o sugerir um nome traficantes
de sonhos roubados faz uma análise
desses jovens deixando de viver
experimentar todas as suas
potencialidades
por que algo se perdeu no curso da sua
infância auto estima afeto família
inclusão pensar
é romper são as fronteiras da mente
a ge é romper com os paradigmas
estabelecidos
nós precisamos dar a vida esses sonhos e
não é só
não é só quando eles são pequenos
crianças nós precisamos que é se esse um
milhão de pessoas que passaram no brasil
possam voltar a sonhar e que irá
trabalhar esse tempo do cárcere que é um
tempo que passa como está passando agora
pra mim é que entendi um tempo que conta
e que eu tenho que fazer e ser produtivo
nós todos precisamos disso então
preocupem se com o tempo de vocês
preocupe-se com o tempo de quem não tem
uma oportunidade e levem as experiências
de vocês pra lugares que vocês
desconhecem a gente tem o instituto
cultural estado de direito agora findou
se a abraçados e acolhidos pra que
possam levar suas vivências
eu trabalho sozinha muitas vezes nem da
galeria porque é um local de alta
complexidade né
mas eu sempre procuro levar voluntários
diferentes porque os voluntários
diferentes são multiplicadores ea gente
precisa de multiplicadores pra quebrar
com o preconceito ea discriminação
muito obrigado